BRADLEY KUHN: I'm Bradley Kuhn.
I'm the president of the
Software Freedom Conservancy.
The Software Freedom Conservancy
is a nonprofit charity.
And our basic mission
is to do for open source
and free software projects
all the things that developers
don't like to do that are
very important for open source
and free software projects.
So developers are very good
at writing great free software
and documentation.
But they're often
not so great at
the organizational and
infrastructural and logistical
work that a nonprofit
can do for them.
So we take care of that
work so the volunteers
can keep writing
great free software.
GSoC is really an amazing
program for the conservancy
because we're an aggregate
umbrella organization.
So we have many different
open source and free software
projects under our umbrella.
And many of those are
in GSoC every year.
It averages between 6%
and 12% of all of GSoC
are Conservancy member projects.
And in fact, we get many new
applicants who come into GSoC
and have a real interest
in joining Conservancy
because it's often the first
moment when they realize
they need
infrastructural services.
And I'll explain what I mean.
Most people don't realize
that GSoC is probably
the largest annual philanthropic
program for open source
and free software
in existence today.
It gives away a tremendous
amount of revenue and resources
to important open source
and free software projects.
And it's often the first
moments that a project realizes
that there might be revenue
coming in-- donations
from Google, for example-- that
need to be handled by someone.
And the best place,
in my view, to handle
that is at a nonprofit
charity, which can then
put the resources to good use
to further advance the project.
So in fact, every year we
get many new applicants
to Conservancy who have
joined the GSoC program
and realized that it would be
just great if they could have
a nonprofit that could handle
the details of the logistics
of coordinating with Google,
to receive the donations,
and to get them to this mentor
summit conference and so forth.
I think that the GSoC program
is incredibly well designed
right now.
And one of the great things
that happens for my organization
through GSoC is it
basically identifies
great new open source
and free software
projects that would make great
members for our organization.
Many of our applicants,
as I mentioned,
have come through
the GSoC program
and decided to apply to us.
And this year we had eight
of our member projects
participating in GSoC.
And my goal really is to
encourage more of our projects
to be engaged and to offer
our services to those
who have discovered GSoC.
They might discover that
they also might find value
in being part of a
nonprofit charity
to do programs like
GSoC elsewhere as well.
So if you run an open source
or free software project
and you don't have any sort
of organizational affiliation
yet-- normally, this is
how most projects exist.
They're a ragtag
band of volunteers
trying to make
great, free software.
They should certainly a look
at Conservancy's website at
sfconservancy.org and look at
our applications' instructions.
We're always welcoming
new applications
of projects that want to have
the benefits of being part
of a nonprofit
organization but want
to stay focused on what
they do best, which
is open source and free
software development.
I believe we were in the
very first GSoC program.
I think we had one
or two projects.
I think our Inkscape
member project
was one of the first
in the very first GSoC.
And every year we've
had more and more
of our projects in GSoC.
Amusingly, percentage
goes down because GSoC
keeps growing so big.
But we always have
at least seven
or eight of our projects
in GSoC every year.
I, myself, have not been
a mentor for a while.
I was a mentor back in 2006.
But I sort of serve the role of
what I call a meadow org admin.
So I coordinate with all the
org admins of our projects
who are in Conservancy.
And I help them do all
those logistical things
I was talking about, like
getting their flights booked
here to the conference, making
sure they get reimbursed,
making it easy for Google to
give money to the projects.
So we do a single invoice for
Google for all our projects.
And the reason we do
that is because we
want to make it easy for Google
to help us and make it easy
for them to process
helping out our projects.
So we try to do our best to
make it very easy for Google
to help out projects.
Well, if you're a
developer, you should
look at all the different
Conservancy projects that
exist and think about
contributing to those.
One of the great things
about the GSoC program
is that it brings together
the most diverse group
of free software projects.
When I look at our organization,
the Software Freedom
Conservancy, we have so many
different member projects
in so many different areas
of free software development.
The mentor summit
is the place that I
can come to see all of
them, because they never
go to the same conference except
for this one, because GSoC has
done such a good job
at bringing together
all these different
free software projects
and getting them to talk
to each other in ways
that really no other
program today does.
The Software Freedom Conservancy
is at sfconservancy.org.
And there are links to all
our member projects there
and information on how
to join and volunteer
for the Software Freedom
Conservancy and our member
projects.